My oncologist responded the address phone about the five-year risk of reoccurrence for my
risk profile doing chemotherapy or just watch and wait observation.
That's your where he got his cystics, but here they are. If I do chemotherapy, I have a 20
in 100 chance of reoccurrence in five years. If I do watch and wait, I have a 30 to 40 in 100
chance of reoccurrence in five years. So the success rate is as 80% with chemotherapy versus
60 to 70% with no chemotherapy. That's sure how significant that is. The grand scheme of things,
thoughts and perspective on those stats. Yeah, to be honest, I do not know where these oncologists
get their statistics because like I said last week, I just cannot believe that they're logging
people into some database, especially people that are opted out of their care.
It's just I just don't know that this that is true. Now there may be a study out there that was
done under 300 people and they watched them over five years. There was a percentage that watched
and wait versus the percentage that did chemotherapy. And if it was a properly conducted study that
would be interested, interested to look at the problem is with the people that watched and wait.
I mean, what's the percentage of if if these statistics were correct based upon whatever data,
you're you're still so it's still so skewed because we're the people that watched and wait a
category of, you know, elderly people that did not want to do chemotherapy because they were too
old and too feeble. You got to think that that was the person that was probably a large percentage
of those people. Number two, were they people that that did have insurance and didn't do other
things that, you know, would be good for their health. They weren't doing any other alternative
things. What percentage of those people that watched and waited in the statistic pool were doing
alternative things as well. I mean, there's a lot of there's a lot of things that can skew this data.
So like any statistics one can make them say whatever they want to say.
So while it's good to have some frame of reference that they're giving you, it's not giving you
enough frame of reference that makes you go, wow, I better do this or that. So you're back to,
otherwise not enough difference there based upon all sorts of variables that could have been
that in those categories that would make me want to go and do chemotherapy. Oh, it would make me
want to do chemotherapy would be, we have statistical data that 90% of the people that do chemotherapy do
not have recurrence in five years and 90% of the people who don't do chemotherapy do have recurrence
in five years. Well then I scratch my head and go boy, I need to really think about that. So
with my cancer it was really easy to make a decision not to because it was, well we have this wonderful
new study from Mayo that showed that doing chemotherapy we had two of 10 people live 15 months.
Okay, well that is so bad that why would anybody want to do that? They just don't think there's
any other options and they were bragging about it. So you know, you're back to, you know,
well I got a 10 or 20% improvement doing chemotherapy by their statistics, but what's the
skewer ratio on that statistical data? I think it's greater than 10 to 20%. So you have to believe that
the people that there's a good percentage of the people in the watch and wave group that are,
that did that there's a lot of the majority of people who choose not to do chemotherapy are the elderly
that just think that are too feeble that they think that the that the chemo will kill them.
The majority of younger people developing cancer are choosing to go to the oncology route.
You know, I will say the majority of people that come to us are, you know, over 50, over 60
that are really seeking our care. We're not getting, you could say, well you're not getting,
there's the people in the 20s don't have cancer. Well that's not necessarily true. And certainly
down after the COVID vaccines, there's more and more people getting cancer. So you know, I don't know
that a 10 to 20% statistical improvement doing chemo based upon their statistics surpasses the error
rate of these statistics for me. But again, you don't look just at this statistics. You look at,
you know, you're, you're, you're comparing a lot of things and what is, you know, hopefully,
you're, you're praying about this and you're asking God for, you know, direction in your care.
And I know you are. And you know, you're just trying to follow that as best you can. And yes,
you coupled it with trying to gain knowledge, you try to gain as much wisdom as possible.
And if you're asking my opinion, I don't know that this 10 to 20% improvement by doing chemo.
Surpasses the error rate in the statistic, the statistical data here. So to be with this would not
be convincing me to do chemo therapy.